I rode shotgun in the lead Humvee and I
looked for bombs stop truck you don't
see the bomb unless they want you to
what you got I don't see nothing there
you don't see he feels it I was a good
soldier I had purpose and I loved it you
kick some ass over there yeah yeah we
wanted it to be perfect I'm home with my
favorite girls it's perfect baby
am I getting my your wife oh yeah you're
getting late it's already 4:00 p.m. in
Baghdad that want chocolate chip smiley
face pancake for you she doesn't like
chocolate okay I guess I missed that
Moni the two Army Commendation medals
and army Achievement Medal impressive
you never told me you were a hero don't
spare me the details I can take anything
but quiet
you are my hammer out there I'll let
these young guys see you Foley so below
yer he did his job not do yours
right no I can't name him after me it's
too perfect
is there a specific incident that
troubles you
you shut down him somewhere
[Music]
I know this don't look like much of a
life but every when I get up I'm
grateful I'm alive because he thank you
for looking after my son a lot of euro
we're brothers ruled after each other
I'm only human after all don't put the
blame on me
you
you